if you find yourself going into a free
fall inside a metal tube hurtling
through the clouds at hundreds of
kilometers per hour and an oxygen mask
drops down right in front of you try not
to panic airplane crashes are highly
survivable and here's what you can do to
increase your chances of survival
according to science taking a flight on
a commercial airplane is about as risky
as riding an escalator the odds of being
killed in a plane crash are 1 in 11
million you're more likely to drown in a
bubble bath choke on your breakfast or
die in a car accident
on your way to the airport yet we can
all feel a little nervous when stepping
on a plane what do you do with this
yellow mask if it suddenly drops from
the ceiling where do you run to in an
emergency evacuation and where is the
safest place on the plane here are 6
things you can do to survive a plane
crash number 1 dress as if you'll have
to run away from a fire your flip-flops
may be comfy but they're not gonna
perform well in case of an emergency and
neither will your high-heeled shoes the
National Transportation Safety Board
reports that 68% of passengers and plane
accidents die from injuries in
post-crash fires so go for long pants
and long sleeved shirts they'll protect
you from flames and sharp objects and
put on lace-up shoes in case you need to
run number two be wise about where your
seat is
where is the safest place to sit anyway
according to an analysis of airplane
crashes by Popular Mechanics your best
bet is to sit as far back in the
airplane as possible unless the plane
goes down tail first you see there's no
such thing as the safest seat on a plane
it all really depends on the situation
regardless of what section you're
sitting in know where the emergency
exits are when you get on the plane
count the rows to the closest one so
that you can find it even if the cabin
is filled with smoke
number three stay awake during takeoff
and landing the first three minutes
after takeoff and the eight minutes
before landing are the most
accident-prone times of the entire
flight make sure to keep your shoes on
your seatbelt fastened and your tray
table up put your carry-on items under
the seat in front of you you know why to
keep your legs from going under the seat
and getting broken and pay attention to
the emergency instructions even if
you've been on a plane many times before
not all planes are the same number four
if you do get in a crash try not to
panic
the first 90 seconds of a plane crash
are the most important many people get
so nervous they forget how to unbuckle
their seatbelt listen carefully to the
instructions but don't just sit through
the disaster waiting for orders if
they're not coming the first thing you
should do is to prepare for impact bend
over grab your legs behind your knees
and keep your head down in the worst
case scenario the cabin will experience
sudden pressure loss and oxygen
deficiency you'll only have about 10
seconds before you go unconscious so if
you see the oxygen masks drop down put
one on yourself first only then should
you try to help someone else
number five save yourself
not your possessions if you get to
evacuate from the plane do it as quickly
as possible
don't try to get your carry-on to take
with you in the time you waste you might
end up getting stuck with it on a
burning plane finally once you're on the
ground get as far away from the crash as
you can if your plane hits the ground
there's a high chance of it
sploded run at least 150 meters away
from it in the direction against the
wind and wait for the rescuers to find
you it's good to be prepared for
anything
but don't be afraid of flying in the
history of aviation it's never been a
safer time to fly commercial aviation
averages less than 500 fatalities per
year worldwide among planes that do get
into accidents over 95% of the
passengers get out of them alive
personally I try to think of turbulence
like bumps on the road helps with my
flying anxiety that's a little tip from
me to you stay tuned for another how-to
according to science
[Music]